coach these plays are from before they
invented the forward pass why is every
guy on our team 40 years I'll tell you
what man you might have players with
your personal brands in your screen
passes sometimes I wish I could just go
back in time man oh thanks for paying
for this time machine instead of Khalil
Mack oh of course Johnny I love chase in
the past bringing me back to when
football was football and men were men
man mm same office same haircut wait I
know you meant coach it's me
Rich Gannon tell you what a reliable
quarterback I'd off the pay I went back
in time man my god Rudin clean tackle
can't wait to practice all offseason
with no restrictions
I'm in heaven oh hi coach have you met
our terrible backup yet hello I'm Thomas
whoops ha ha ha thank goodness for the
Tuck rule even clumsy rookie idiots can
drop the ball and it's still not a
fumble mark you gotta bring me back 20
18 Shrek I'm sorry but his brain is
trapped in 2002 forever and that's the
Raider way